Oh, this gon be good.
(cookie crunching)
Oh my gosh!
(upbeat music)
- All right y'all today is
national Girl Scout day.
I was a girl scout.
I don't know if you knew that,
I was excited about it,
winning the patches.
Actually, my girl is now,
my seven year old daughter
wants to be girl scout.
She just told me last night,
that's real.
Girl Scout Cookie season is currently
taking over America.
There are so many amazing flavors
and I know everyone has
their own favorites.
However, because of my expert,
finely tuned taste buds,
I have been officially selected
by myself to taste
and rank every single cookie flavor.
So we can finally know once and for all
that Thin Mint is the best cookie
that Girl Scouts sell.
(TV beeps)
And we can finally once and for all
which flavor is the best one
but it's gonna be hard to
be thin mint for me, people.
This may just be my opinion,
but my opinion is,
well it rings true for all things.
So you're welcome in advance.
I thought this would just be fun to do
cause cookies are good.
(upbeat music)
Adventurefuls!
Okay.
Indulgent, brownie inspired cookies
with caramel flavored cream,
cream,
and a hint of sea salt.
This is gonna be awesome.
I'm gonna try one.
I've never had, is this new?
I've never heard of this one before.
Let's see how adventurous it is.
(cookie crunching)
(epic music)
That's a good cookie.
I love this job.
Adventurefuls.
We have Samoas,
these are classic.
Crisp cookies with caramel coconut
and dark chocolatey stripes.
Come on.
I'm gonna taste one for y'all but
lets be real I've had some
Samoas in my lifetime.
Mm. This is such a good one.
Oh and the coconut at the end.
That's a good cookie.
That's better than Adventurefuls.
It just is.
It's not an opinion.
It's not subjective.
It just is.
These are the Do-si-dos.
How country are these?
Do-si-do.
These are oatmeal sandwich cookies
with peanut butter filling.
Well, this gon be good.
Okay, here we go.
(cookie crunching)
That's a good cookie,
but they're not Samoas.
So far out of these top three,
out of Adventurefuls,
Samoas
and Do-si-dos,
it's still the classic Samoas, y'all.
These are still winning so far.
Boom.
You're welcome America.
Girl Scout s'mores.
I've never heard of these,
so these have to be new.
Graham sandwich cookies with chocolate
and marshmallow filling.
How do you go wrong is
the real question, here.
Let's taste it.
(cookie crunching)
Oh my God.
These are real good too.
Samoas is still better.
It's classic.
Lemon-ups I've never heard of,
I like lemon.
I'm gonna like this, probably.
Lemon-ups,
crispy lemon cookies
baked with inspiring messages
to lift your spirits.
Baked with inspiring messages,
get it Girl Scouts,
just bringing cheer to the world.
Here we go.
Oh,
that's,
okay...
I didn't get it.
I was just like whatever with the wording.
Okay wait, this is,
I'm a risk taker.
Am I?
I don't know.
I am an innovator.
I am a go-getter.
(cookie crunching)
No one comes close to Samaos yet,
but that's because we
haven't gotten to Thin Mints.
Let's be real.
Tagalongs,
crispy cookies layered with peanut butter
and covered with a chocolatey coating.
I don't know how you go wrong there.
That sounds pretty awesome.
It's interesting that
its name is Tagalong,
cause I feel like it's
just trying to rip off
the vibe of a Thin Mint.
I mean it's not the same flavor,
it just kinda looks as same,
it's deceiving.
You know, late at night,
you're getting in your kitchen,
you're like Ooh, a thin
mint and then it's not.
That's what I feel like
a Tagalong represents
in my heart right now.
Tagalongs.
Okay. Ooh.
Smells good.
(cookie crunching)
Nope.
No.
Tagalong,
Nope. You ain't.
No,
no third wheels allowed.
You're not allowed on my dates.
I don't like Tagalongs,
turns out.
Maybe you do.
You would be wrong.
Trefoils,
I've never heard of this either.
Girl Scouts got fancy since
I've been in the Girl Scouts.
Trefoils.
What is this, French?
Oh, shortbread cookies,
this is gonna be awesome.
This is gonna be amazing,
I love shortbread.
(cookie crunching)
That's your classic shortbread cookie.
That's good.
That's just a solid staple flavor.
(hands rubbing)
Here we go people!
Thin mints.
This box is going home with me,
I hope you know that.
These, this is where it's at.
All the patches are awesome,
but when I became a Girl Scout
and I was introduced to this cookie,
this is an amazing cookie.
If you freeze these bad boys,
whoa,
you are so good.
Crisp chocolatey cookies made
with natural oil of peppermint.
I'm gonna go ahead
and just keep that.
That's, I mean,
I'm gonna put it here
cause it's like in front of these,
cause I don't have too.
Look, I didn't even take a bite.
This cookie is so good.
No cooking on planet Earth
tops the Thin Mint for me.
Sorry.
I think I like peppermint
and chocolate though.
Cause also, I like an Andes mint.
Those ones that are like,
oh they give you like Olive Garden,
when you're leaving.
It's like with the check
and you're like...
...so good.
And you're like, oh you're
not gonna eat that one?
Okay, I will.
It's really good.
Thin mints are still the,
I'm just gonna put these back.
They just don't even,
these don't even belong anymore.
It's just there.
Samoas are a close second.
It's the coconut.
Okay, this is Toffee-tastic.
I'm not excited about this.
I'm just gonna be real.
Aw.
And it says gluten free,
which,
which is good for you
and totally what I should be eating,
says my blood work.
But, here's the thing,
I'm probably gonna taste
that it's gluten free.
Here we go.
Toffee-tastic.
(cookie crunching)
Hard to bite in to..
No.
This cookie represents
a Butter Finger to me
the candy bar that gets
stuck in your teeth
for what seems days.
I don't like things that get
stuck in your teeth like that.
Here's the thing.
The only ones I didn't like are Tagalongs
and Toffee-Tastic.
But...
(boxes thud)
There's only one real winner people
and that's Thin Mints.
And I probably having 'em
in my teeth right now.
Well, actually,
I think I still have Toffee-Tastic
but that's the thing,
if you like having something
hang out for a minute
you will like Toffee-tastic.
Thin mints breakfast of champions.
Look, this is close.
Simoas are close.
This is a damn good cookie.
It's just not this cookie.
Um so it's official.
I was correct.
Not joking.
Thin Mints are the best cookies,
Samoas a close second.
Let me know in the comments below
if you have a different favorite flavor.
I don't care
because you know why,
your taste are your taste,
and mine are mine.
And this is where it's at,
but I am happy for you,
Toffee-Tastic people out there.
You like it to hang out a bit,
that's cool.
And go support your local girls y'all.
Bye.
Help 'em get the patches.
I love the patches.
All right, I'm gonna take these with me.
Okay, later.
That's real.